Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
June 4th,
2018.
What's going on?
How are you,
how you doing Lottie?
I'm in Dublin,
Dublin,
Ireland.
Um,
I've been on a fucking plane for,
I don't know how long.
Uh,
we left lax and uh,
what were you supposed to leave in the afternoon?
And then,
uh,
there was some problem with the hydraulics.
They back the fucking thing up.
They pulled it forward to back that up.
They pulled it forward like,
you know,
two and a half hours later we finally left,
which is all good cause you know,
it's Don Rickles says,
and casino rather,
it's,
you know,
it's better down here then you know,
up there.
Right.
Um,
so I was just sitting on the fucking plane and uh,
they didn't give us any food.
They get a little cup of water.
It was it two and a half hours,
the late nothing,
no food,
no drinks or anything and all,
I was thinking,
I was on Air France there.
I was like,
oh,
this is how these fucking people stay so skinny.
You know,
they just leave you on there.
They don't feed you or nothing.
MMM.
So anyways,
but I kept my mind occupied.
I was transcribing a pan terrorists song.
I get into shit,
you know,
I fucking eats up all the time
rather than sitting there,
I didn't do that.
Or I play solitaire on my phone.
It's somebody get me a deck of cards.
They're like,
you know,
you can just get an app for that.
I'm like,
that is really a lot easier isn't it?
Plus I feel you win a lot more with the APP.
You know,
cause it wants you to keep playing or a deck of cards.
They don't give a shit.
They just want it done.
They got your money that done that fucking solitaire game though.
Don't get it.
Because they got like 50 fucking ads every time they shuffle the cards.
Every time you win a game,
every time you move your hand,
they got like another ad.
They put the x in a different spot every time.
If you don't really hit the x and it goes to another fucking page,
you know,
so somebody gets credit for,
I'll look of viewing a click and I don't know,
I don't,
I don't pretend to understand these things.
So anyways,
yeah.
MMM.
This podcast is going to be a all over the place.
I'm going to tell you that right now because I was debating whether or not to do
it,
uh,
before I left.
And I was like,
well,
don't do it before you leave.
It'd be more exciting if people hear you talk to yourself in a different country
that allowed a new fucking flavor.
MMM.
They gave me this crazy room.
Oh Shit.
My Room Service.
Hang on a second.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
It just ate my fucking room service and I put on the,
the news over here.
It's just like the news back home.
All depressing shit I got with a gun though.
But this is the difference between the U S in Ireland.
It was a 38 Smith and Wesson with five rounds of ammunition.
When they said what kind of gun it wasn't how much ammunition was there.
I almost went aw.
Oh,
fucking hilarious.
Is that um,
yeah.
Not about gloom and doom.
Tara t one people right here.
Look here today when a tractor went off,
it's fucking rails is at Hash hate hard.
A fucking volcano erupted down in Guatemala and [inaudible] have a hood and
habits,
you know,
great accents and everything,
but just all depressing shit
at grand mother was later yesterday.
Today
when she was found half eaten by her cat.
If,
if we can divide this too.
I'm
sorry,
I'm fucking punch drunk.
I fucking just ordered this shit or a BLT.
Not the most healthiest thing.
There was no bacon in it.
It's that uh,
rest of the World Bacon,
you know where it looks like him,
but it has the consistency of fucking Lod was delicious.
And I ordered the side salad.
I specifically said side salad,
no fucking fatalities.
Right.
And they still brought me French fries.
I have the side salad,
but you know it is,
if you see fucking French fries sitting there and there's a salad,
right?
The Salad,
that's the plain gene girl next door.
You want to fuck that big at horror up the street,
right?
You're going to go after the cup of potato dish.
Fucking man is mayonnaise over here.
He can't,
he can't have the ketchup over here.
Although they brought up some heights.
European ketchup sucks.
It's all natural there.
Yogurt sucks.
It's also all natural.
You know,
I can't even get through a cup of it.
All right?
If I'm not like got it.
You know,
at least four cups of sugar in an eight ounce thing of yogurt.
Like that's not yoga to me.
Um,
I charity one year old retired,
which can lead to,
we did your phd or would five rounds at the mediation.
The town was so shaken up,
they took the night off to go out and go drink.
Um,
this has been the Irish news.
and he was with the fuck.
Am I here?
I'm in Dublin.
What did I just write?
Berlin is my password.
Fucking idiot.
I really am done.
What do you guys listen to this?
I mean,
I appreciate that you listen to it,
but I really questioned you sometimes.
Um,
greatest thing about Ireland by the way,
it's going through customs now.
Granted,
I look like a fucking Leprechaun,
you know,
an older one who's getting who a bald.
All right?
It looked like a Leprechaun.
So uncle.
Okay.
Um,
they just let shit,
no work papers.
No,
nothing goes like,
what are you doing here lady?
And I was like,
I'm doing a show all by yourself.
I was like,
Yep.
He's like,
all right.
They have a good one.
Welcome to the country.
You know
the other place you go to,
you get that fucking guy looks.
He's like,
you seen the Bourne identity looking you up and down.
And he just starts thinking,
why you making me feel like I have drugs in my ass right now?
You know,
like I'm a mule.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm here.
God dammit.
Hang on a second.
All right.
Sorry.
Look adjusted from the Goddamn flight.
You know,
sleeping in that recliner.
MMM
No,
you fall asleep on him on an airplane.
You're always like,
this must be what it's like to be in a loveless marriage.
You know,
we just don't want to go upstairs because your wife's in bed and you just watch
TV to fall asleep and you fall.
You just lay in there and they're fucking lazy boy,
you know,
or you've been married so long that like,
oh,
I don't want to go up the stairs.
You just sleep right on the couch
doing that shit all night.
Um,
I actually had a dream.
I couldn't fucking breathe.
I have that dream.
I don't know.
I don't do well on airplanes.
I watched the 250 greatest goals and soccer and uh,
you know,
there was some nice ones.
There was some pretty pedestrian ones,
but I think it was also because it's so fucking hard to score.
And he also said the top 250,
250.
Okay.
Like who has the fucking time?
I'm glad somebody did it.
It took like it was,
it was the perfect soccer highlight reel for an American.
I got to sit there for like 24 minutes and watch nothing but goals,
you know?
I bet goalies hate that fucking highlight reel.
It's like a fucking snuff film to them.
You know you don't scrape.
I have noticed about soccer is when you score and your blasted by the goalie
high on either side,
it's e they jump out of the water like a fucking sword fish.
It looks like you know.
No,
no,
the water,
they jump up like a,
like a sword fish coming out of the water.
And what's amazing is rather than just jumping up in fucking trying to block it,
they always have to turn around and watch it go in the net.
You know,
it's like the Matrix.
Don't you think he could jump a little higher if you want some goddamn concern.
Do you know where the fuck it's going?
If it got by ag nowhere it is.
You know he can hear the crowd.
You fucking piece of shit.
Right.
You know when it,
okay.
Oh he's fucking look at this God damn soccer goalies there.
There,
there are no nosy group of people.
Okay,
I missed it.
Where's it going?
Right in the back of the net.
Okay.
No,
I actually,
I didn't even look.
Are there like safety nets or anything behind,
has anybody ever died?
Somebody blast the ball,
misses the net and then hit some fucking kid in the face.
That's the only thing that was missing from the Irish News.
Oh,
we look at daddy went down to the pitch.
Took a fork and soccer ball too.
You don't know [inaudible]
he'll be laid to rest
half six tomorrow morning.
Okay.
That'd be really early fucking funeral.
Um,
get it over with.
We're all fucking pasty over here.
The thing worst and bettering your son after he got hit in the face on the pitch
is getting a fucking sunburn.
My accent,
I can't do the Irish accent.
My wife reminded me of that guy that met me at the airport when I was in
Scotland.
Remember that?
That story I get off and the guy at the same,
it had my name on.
I came walking up on my hay and he just goes,
hello.
Okay.
I'm like,
what your preferred bottle wall?
Who Do you prefer?
Bill or William Bolo.
Bolo.
Um,
how much?
Jesus Christ,
it's only been 10 minutes.
Fuck.
Oh Man.
I should have called in sick.
Um,
you know what I always mean to do when I go to Dublin is to take a tour of the
Guinness Factory.
You know,
I'm not,
I am not big on going to fuck on tours.
I don't want to hear about it.
Oh.
They get his family,
they fuckin,
you know,
they first made their first bite.
I don't care.
Just get to the part where I get my pint,
you know.
Oh.
But here's where we put the hops and the hops score and a big hopper Robbie had.
And then they stood them up or Seamus gets on a bicycle,
it's got some paddles on it and he go,
he wheels around.
I'm going to keep my voice down.
People think I'm really disrespected.
I was going for right now.
MMM.
This giant fucking Queen Elizabeth.
Fuck.
It's you in a big room like this Sealy.
So like,
okay,
this is like for shack or something.
MMM.
But I never ended up fucking getting down there.
It's kind of stupid though,
right?
I mean,
I bet I could go in online and just see a video.
I know what it tastes like.
Yeah.
Kind of a degenerate alcoholic.
Are you think you know I,
there's a bunch of booze I like,
I'm not going to go there and see how they make it.
Yeah.
Salivating the whole tour.
Getting the fucking shakes.
Oh Man.
Would you like to just dive in there?
How 17 year old fell into a vat of Guinness.
Hey Joel in cause he was burned from a volcano and Guatemala.
He got to jump in the ocean to Guatemala,
but he was Irish.
So we took the pain all the way back to London because he didn't want to
inconvenience anybody with his own emotions.
Um,
uh,
fucking new,
a fun over here,
man.
Uh,
this is going to be a good time.
My Show's tomorrow night at the three arena.
I don't know what that stands for.
It sounds like some Illuminati shit to me.
What was it?
The three banks that are left and all of Europe.
Are they part of the European Union here?
Who decided to leave?
Was it Brussels?
No.
Was it Berlin?
Nope.
Was it Great Britain?
I knew it was Brexit,
so I just try to guess all the Br.
Once I spell Berlin,
I preempt the Ar Brelyn um,
just to be interesting,
you know,
just,
just to try to keep it fresh globally,
you know.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
how about those fucking Washington capitals?
I'll say it again.
How about those fucking Washington capitals?
Tell you right now,
if I'm a fan of the Vegas Knights,
I gotta be thinking what is my,
what is our adjustment to their adjustment going to happen?
All right,
I'm going to go out and look.
This is waste of what happened.
Okay.
The capital's whatever the Fuck Vegas was doing in game one,
the capital's adjusted to it.
I think game three,
I did not see an answer by the Vegas Knights.
Okay.
Uh,
as far as my limited knowledge of math goes,
they better fucking respond in game four or this series going to be fucking
over.
Okay.
No vet skin's going to be on the cops.
Gotta be great.
Either way.
It's,
it's a,
it's an incredible,
it's going to be great.
I mean,
I'm rooting for the capital's cause.
The Josh,
Adam Meyers and um,
okay.
You know,
and they plus everybody down there.
They'd been waiting since 1974 the Redskins suck the nationals,
you know,
I don't,
they used to be the senators or the Senate is twice they left.
One time they became the fucking Texas rangers and other time they became the
Minnesota twins and the fucking expos came down to some nationals and they still
haven't won a title.
You know,
they're on their third fucking marriage.
Actually,
the senator's did want a title and like the 1920s,
I think
they went to the fucking White House.
Thank George Washington was still there when it showed up.
It's fucking wouldn't teeth.
You had to sit there and listen to,
I'm boring story how he said they made a bat.
Maybe it's the teeth out of his fucking Bazzi had as a kid.
How much is it?
The guy lied his ass off that they had to come up with that dumb ass story about
I can't,
I can't.
I can't tell a lie.
I chopped down the cherry tree.
What kind of ass kicking do you think he got over that?
You know,
when you really think about it?
Back then there was no supermarkets in the sky just chopped down a fucking tree
that actually had edible fruit on it.
You know,
it was dad probably beat him with the ax handle,
knock their fucking powdered wig right off his head.
Okay.
Did rich kids wear powdered wigs back then?
You know,
people would come up with key their horse
a shit.
Fuck you guys.
I've been on a plane for 12 hours.
I don't give a fuck if this is funny.
You know,
I mean I do,
I do care.
But anyways,
um,
okay.
Anyways,
so,
uh,
I watched game one of the NBA finals.
Uh,
and I have to tell you when they fucking reversed that offensive foul call that
basically every summit jr Smith and I can't get mad at chair Smith cause I
didn't know what the score was either when he was dribbling it out and I was
going,
yes,
yes.
It was a lot of other people too that thought that thought they were up by one.
MMM.
The game was over on that offensive file.
And uh,
you know,
I've never seen them have a little powwow and reverse a call.
It's easy.
I mean,
I just,
I had like Tourette's when that happened and I was so fucking upset.
And so once again,
disappointed by the NBA and the way that they fucking run their league,
I was so mad.
I walked to my show that night.
I just,
I didn't want to get in the fucking car.
I need,
I had to go for a fucking wall.
I didn't watch the overtime because I knew,
I knew the words are going to win it.
I've watched enough games that when a fucking
kicking the balls with a call like that,
and then the rain man,
dude on your team doesn't know that you fucking tongue tied and he runs out the
club.
I,
you know,
what's going to happen.
So Lebron knew,
that's why he went back to the bench and he didn't talk to anybody.
I fucking,
I had two shows in La and I walked a both of them,
yeah,
at one in a dive bar.
And then another one add a little more upscale place that wasn't quite a comedy
club and I just,
I just walked to both of them and I could tell you this right now.
La has an unbelievable homeless problem.
Okay.
Holy Shit.
I mean,
they are fucking everywhere.
Every doorway,
every nook and cranny.
There's somebody you know,
wrapped up in a like a fucking cocoon.
Okay.
A lot of mental illness out there.
It's unreal.
It's really unreal how
we just fucking leave those people on the street,
you know,
mentally ill people.
Yeah.
Oh No.
You still have those asylums.
She can't.
Yeah.
I don't know.
That didn't work.
I Dunno.
I just need to try to take care of him.
It was really fucking depressing.
Then I was sitting there walking down the street going like,
did I really leave the safety of my car to fucking
okay.
Walk amongst all these fucking people who've got God knows what kind of issues.
Right.
And I was standing there and this guy with this really dirty shirt was just
staring at me and I'm waiting for the light to say walk.
You know,
it's La.
You can't,
Jay Walk,
you'll get killed,
right?
And then I feel him.
He's just staring right at me.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
here we go.
Here we go.
Oh,
freckles couldn't take your car.
Could you get all mad about a basketball game?
Right.
Guy Looks at me and he goes,
hey.
And I ignore him
was hey,
I ignore him again.
And then he sorta like walked around Susan,
my vision.
He goes,
Hey,
I looked at him,
I go,
what?
And he goes,
are you chilling Mikael?
I just go,
no.
Yeah.
Then it said walk.
And I walked away from,
and I felt a behind me
and I just kept walking.
Then I was walking too fast.
So then there was somebody in front of me and then he's doing this whole kind of
looking back like,
why is this guy walking so quick?
You know?
And I wanted to say to the guy,
hey,
you don't need to worry about me.
It's the guy.
I'm walking away from it.
Um,
anyways,
so that's what the fuck I did after game one.
Jesus Christ,
the warriors have to be the most hateable fucking team I've ever seen in my
life.
You don't get enough stars on your team.
You got to poke Lebron in the eye.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That's some shit I fucking girl would do playing nerf basketball,
fucking disgrace.
And then Lebron gets out there with his old ass body,
takes a fucking charge.
I know his foot was work was moving and I know that would,
after they looked at it,
you know,
they did get the call.
Right.
But what the fuck they,
they've never reversed something like that,
that ever.
So like they were looking for a way for the warriors to fuck it when it was
just,
it just,
uh,
I don't,
I don't know why I give a shit so much.
Why do I give a fuck about either one of these teams?
Yeah.
I,
cause what I'm rooting for is for sports to go back to the way they used to be,
where,
uh,
there was still free agency.
I'm not that old when I was growing up,
but there wasn't these pylons fucking tapes,
you know,
I dunno,
somebody sent me a thing about Lebron could possibly go to the Celtics.
He better not,
I don't want that title,
you know,
I dunno.
Bill,
you just old and all you do is complain.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I can't,
I just realize that the game isn't what it was when I was a kid and this new
game,
young people seem to be enjoying it.
Don't have a problem with it.
Should be in a way.
Where did it happen?
When I was a kid,
there was an old man playing in Oregon.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
let me do a little bit advertising reads,
there's this podcast,
I'm not going to make it.
Our people,
you know,
by the way,
this is my last week of my forties.
This is it,
man.
I turned 50 years old on Sunday.
Can you believe that?
I was 39 when I started this podcast.
Way back when,
way back in 2007,
man.
Okay.
When a guy named George W.
Bush was president and he was a son of a guy,
George Herbert Walker Bush,
and he,
he was the vice president of a guy named Ronald Reagan,
who,
who used to be an actor
and your first four,
look at,
think about everything that has happened since I've started since I was 39 years
old.
Oh,
robots are gonna take over the world.
Miami,
she's going to be under Miami.
Miami's going to be underwater
reality TV show star.
Okay.
Became fucking president.
We're still fighting the same fucking war.
That's the one constant,
that's the one thing you can hang your hat on.
It'd be like,
oh,
okay,
this is something I'm comfortable with.
There's something I'm used to who says you can never go home.
Yeah.
How long was it before I understood that?
I've talked about that before.
Right.
When they say you never can go home with the fuck you talking about a book,
a flight right now and go home.
I never understood that they meant you're going to go and it's not gonna be the
same people and it's just going to be overwhelmingly fucking depressant.
Yeah.
Well anyways,
yeah,
I'm turning 15.
I actually feel good about it.
Dan got 50 push ups the other day.
Right.
That means I'm not going to die.
Um,
no.
My forties where my best decade as far as my life,
I got married,
I had a kid,
right.
Did a bunch of great shows,
got rid of all the fucking assholes in my life.
Cleaned house,
cleaned fucking house.
Anybody that was a fucking bigger contin.
Me,
you know,
I got of,
so obviously it was a short list.
Sorry.
Easy joke.
What do you,
what do you want from me?
Huh?
What do you want to,
I've been on a fucking plane for the last fucking 12 hours.
Um,
so I'm looking forward to another decade of experiences and knowledge gaining,
just living my truth.
I feel like for me,
my fifties are going to be
okay.
No,
I'm going to crush it.
My fifties.
Okay.
I'm going to yoga.
Eat a plant based diet.
Take a whole bunch of selfies.
Hashtag fifties hot,
hot,
50 something stupid like that.
What about the forever 21 is for an old white guy over 50.
Whatever that Hash you guys,
you guys come up with the Hashtag.
You can put the Hashtag and I'll start hashtagging it on fucking what is it?
What would the Hashtag App?
MMM,
you guys like Hash.
Remember Hash it be your mother used to make cash.
I have the little fucking meat grinder.
Why the Fuck Oh Hashtag this way met Ryan?
Good.
All right,
let's,
let's read a little bit advertising here.
Okay.
Authority tour year old.
All right.
Uh,
the black talks,
everybody wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big.
You're married if Patrick and going out to all the,
all of your buddies weddings.
Uh,
when you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
Exactly.
You want to look the best she can,
but you don't want to be.
You don't have to be a pain in the ass.
That's where the black tux comes in.
Everybody,
the Black Tux has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles.
And your rent them online.
Yeah,
rent them.
You go out,
you'll hook up.
Yep.
Bang.
And you give it back to him.
The black Tux offers the kinds of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally
be wildly expensive to buy.
And you might only wear it once.
That's right.
You go to a wedding and then you've got that suit.
You just waiting for someone to die.
Now,
like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo,
it's foggy.
It's cool.
But how many times are you going to wear that shit?
An Emerald Green Tuxedo.
Okay.
What do you,
what do you,
unless you were the mascot for fucking Notre Dame,
you going away that they one time right there,
green alligator and along.
You look so great last night and I said,
that's going to be sitting in there with the Black Tux.
You can do,
you can do you.
Oh Jesus.
Okay.
Oh,
they're going to tell me,
keep my voice down.
Hang on a sec.
I'm going to leave it on for this.
No
worries.
We'll see.
I thought I was going to get yelled at.
It hasn't happened since I was in Jersey.
Hello Ms. Dot binder which I turned down at every
what I what?
It's a lot of you have a really sound we ours around the English language to
come to Ireland
cause we are second par.
Um,
poor park.
We are fucking par.
Um,
so try out the new look,
do something different and take your style to the next level with the Black Tux
free home.
Try on a,
you can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
After ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect.
Like if you went out and got Nachos or something,
the black,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
I remember how simple returns are where it turn heads.
Then send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free.
Both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the black tux.com/burr that's the black tux.com/birth for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
Okay?
Simply safe.
Okay.
You know it's important to protect your home with the home security system.
Considering these fucking labels more and take away all the guns.
You might as well get a safe
fucking sleeping.
That shit.
How can we protect your home and your privacy?
That's what I love about simply safe.
They obsess over details like no or home security company.
Here's an example.
Simply safe has a camera you can control from your phone,
but they want to protect your home and your privacy.
So they came up with this brilliant idea,
a private shutter for their camera.
Now simply safe wanted you to be able to hear the shutter click so you know it's
closed.
They wanted to have a light on it so you could easily tell when it's on and they
needed to work for the entire lifespan of the system.
I Dunno what I'm talking about right now.
So simply safe.
Got To work.
Testing different metals in hinge designs for months and months.
The result and effective home security camera with a thin,
lightweight aluminum privacy shutter that will work every time.
It's the kind of attention to detail that sets simply safe apart,
and keeps your family safe.
Simply safe isn't just home security,
home security done right.
Checkout simply safe today@simplysafebird.com that's simply safe bird.com learn
more about simply safe today.
Simply say [inaudible] dot com by the way,
when you get home security,
don't get cameras in your house.
Just get them outside.
All right,
cause you know what?
That pervert down there hacking and assist and watching you fucking your wife.
All right,
me undies,
everybody or you jerking off on the toilet?
Yeah,
me is everybody.
You've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
You know the fun comfy undies.
Oh,
but dude,
dude,
me,
undies,
me undies,
slap and you are a fucking prick.
The dude dude,
dude,
be our days,
be on days with a fucking selfie stick.
But you got security looking at yo now they know you're come face.
What are you do you get a two pairs of fucking me undies?
One for your junk and then your face.
Um,
you've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
You know the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good as they look to those of you.
You haven't who haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get an incredible underwear sent to your door with me.
Undies.
Meaning no more hunting around for the perfect pair at a crowded store and
eventually setting settling for good enough.
Mondays is so sure you'll love the first pair.
You,
if not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you the right pair.
And if they can't keep up and they were fine.
Yeah.
Oh,
they're gonna walk away and be the martyr.
No,
it's fine.
Keep it.
Sorry.
I'm sorry we couldn't please you.
So it's really is risk free to try the best underwear ever.
And if you're already part of the me undies fam,
okay,
tell your friends about it through their referral program.
Okay,
that's like Amway,
but with underwear they'll get a discount and you'll get a store credit when?
When still's not sure.
Wow me.
Andy's has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 20% off their first pair of [inaudible] and free
shipping.
That's a team that's 20% off plus free shipping
and a guarantee that you and your [inaudible] will be very happy together.
Get your butt over to [inaudible] dot com and treat yourself to get your 20% off
your first pair.
Free Shipping,
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bro that's me,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr and lastly,
but not leastly always headline stamps.com the u s postal service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
That's why they don't want me to trash the post office because they use them.
I get it now.
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven,
I got the hiccups because they ate those French fries,
those freedom fries.
Uh,
print postage for any male class right now from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage,
every time.
Never underpay or overpay again.
stamps.com saves you time and money.
Uh,
when you could,
you which you can use to grow your business.
Okay.
Mail any letter,
any package using again to get my computer,
a printer and a mail carrier picks it up.
Yeah.
Oh,
from your left set of to God's ears.
Create your stamps.com account and minutes online with no equipment to lease
with no long term commitments.
Click print and mail and you're done.
Uh,
it's convenient.
It's easy,
it's reliable,
it's efficient.
You know,
what else do you want from an,
I use stamps.com to send out my fucking posters that are going to be selling
tonight.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com and click on the microphone.
It's off the homepage and type in [inaudible].
That's stamps.com enter a bar,
B U R R buyer.
That's a fucking English name.
Um,
it's an English surname.
All right,
33 minutes in
Chai tea tree edited.
All right,
should I just get to the questions here?
Think I shouldn't.
All right,
so they have a Jimmy or why did I eat those fries?
I feel like shit.
Okay.
I hate when they do that.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how alcoholics doing.
You know when they sit there and they go,
yeah,
you know,
no boost for me.
Then they bring a beer.
They always go,
I,
you know,
I don't drink.
What's if they brought a fucking crack pipe up your rights,
smoke it.
That's how,
that's how weak I am.
I don't even smoke crack.
Not at least.
At least not during the week.
All right,
great news.
Flameout Yo,
Billy Nova.
Uh,
did you hear the great news?
You finally have representation on the Emoji front.
They added orange headed people to the Emoji list.
Nice.
Now you can let people you text.
No,
you really look at the moment how you really look at the moment.
You say for me,
I got to check these out.
Let's see.
You go to the page.
Yes.
That's what I would like to do.
Okay.
Oh no,
those look like me.
They're all so young.
Okay.
Add closed by Google.
Stop seeing this ad.
Yes.
Yeah,
I already but not interested in this ad.
We'll try not to show it again.
Okay.
Get outta here.
Beat it.
I hate when you scroll down in the ad goes with you.
Like that person that's just fucking tagging along.
You know,
you're trying to hook up.
It's like,
get outta here.
Okay.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Would you look at these fucking things?
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't look like any of these people.
Well that's nice.
That's not really accurate.
I mean they should.
They should have at least one really pasty
couple of people of color in there.
Then they got some,
no,
nobody was blue eyes.
A couple of Simpson's colored people or Emoji colored now.
Well that's nice.
It's nice that they're doing it.
I bet.
I mean quit my age.
Sends out an Emoji.
Do you know,
you know what emojis I use I all the one that I used the most thumbs up.
Okay.
Thumbs up.
What I love about thumbs up is it means,
uh,
okay.
Yes,
I definitely want to do that.
Or it means like fucking whatever.
We got to get together sometime man.
Hang up the arms up,
not fucking hanging out with you.
Right.
Or it could be like,
fuck yeah,
get out there fucking drag.
Um,
all right.
I should have made a top 10 lists of what I could do.
What am,
what am I going to do here to make my fifties you know,
the best me lived your truth.
Do you realize like the amount of shit that's going on in the world right now.
Okay.
And just to how self involved myself and club and literally doing a podcast,
just talking to myself,
how's fucking self involved?
The world is right now,
you know,
live your truth.
Be the best.
You've fifty's the new 40
you know,
everything has to be like,
come on with us for,
so that's why you got those fucking assholes who work out in the garage and then
they start running down the streets.
Everybody knows they will crossfit people.
Right?
Everybody knows they're working out.
It's like we get it,
Yo,
I work out too.
I don't get to fucking start yelling at people who are having brunch.
Okay.
I don't know.
You know something that,
that right there,
you can remember a few years ago they decided to do away with bullying.
Okay.
All right.
Which you know,
is a great thing,
but I think you should be able to bully adults because the fact that that's,
you know,
it's not,
it's out of style to bully people.
Yeah.
I think is how crossfit actually exists.
You know,
if you basically categorize any sort of criticism is bullying.
how are you going to know when you're acting like a complete fucking tool?
Shit,
I just don't understand.
I don't find those crossfit people to be in any better shape than anybody else
doing any other workout.
And they had just parading up and down the fucking street.
Yeah.
Like,
I dunno what,
like they're inspirational.
I Dunno.
I've never liked,
you know,
I don't like people that do end zone dances.
I just don't like any of that shit.
It's just fucking,
and it's just,
it gives me Deuce chills to look at it.
I Dunno.
Maybe it's a good workout.
I'm going to start doing that,
you know,
do pull ups in my garage and then run up and down my driveway yelling shit.
So my neighbors know that I just did a set of 10 fucking pull ups.
The Bern,
um,
Lebron is Celtic here.
Kay.
Who is the question?
Hey there,
Billy.
Not from Boston.
Uh,
what if Lebron went to Boston?
Kind of goes without saying that winning with Lebron wouldn't feel as good as
winning without Lebron thoughts.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What am I the president?
You just fucking give me a half ass fucking question.
I gotta answer.
I know.
Yeah.
Obviously,
obviously I'm a,
yeah,
I would rather beat Lebron and fucking them.
Just join my team and then everybody like why it's a fucking pile on team.
It gives a shit a bunch of championship.
Yeah,
obviously.
Thank you,
sir.
Those are my thoughts.
I have the obvious thought on that.
No,
I don't want that to happen.
I would like us to continue doing what we're doing.
We already signed a big free agent with a,
what's his face there that hurt his knee?
Uh,
ginger Vitus what the fuck is his name?
I Dunno.
I'm not,
I'm on a Celtic,
don't know sound something.
I'm just not a basketball guy.
Um,
and I missed all the games this year.
All right.
I got a kid,
man.
I got a kid and I,
I miss a lot of stuff.
The guy with the beard who thinks the world is flat,
right?
Is that the guy?
That's the guy again.
I just want to see,
you know,
it's like the New York Yankees,
New York Yankees,
you know,
they,
they built off of their farm team and drafting and all that fucking shit,
and then they added one that's fucking stud from the Marlins there.
Can't get mad at that.
MMM.
Wait,
a couple of shrewd trades.
We did give up Isaiah Thomas stuff.
Quite swear to God,
if he still was still with the Celtics,
he woulda got his own.
He was like,
he's going to be a big Papi of the Celtics.
A whale of a tale bill.
Did you hear this?
Did you hear about this whale?
MMM.
By the way,
has anybody seen that fucking
okay
video,
that poor girl calling up if her ex boyfriend crying,
it's,
she literally sounds like the impression me and Paul do when we,
when we do the crying thing,
right?
Ooh.
She'd be like,
hello.
I'm sorry I missed your call.
Okay.
I really hope you call me back.
I love you now.
Do you want me to say that I love you and I miss you,
Huh?
I'm not even,
I'm not even exaggerating.
Yeah.
I'm really sad that I missed your call.
Ooh,
fucking unbelievable.
All right.
Pilot whale dies in Thailand after being found with 17 pounds of plastic bags
and its stomach.
Yeah.
And also say get excited because they had fucking ginger emojis.
Oh my God.
This is just what,
what are we,
what are we doing?
Oh Man.
A male pilot whales struggled for five days to stay alive and Thailand near the
Malaysian border.
I'll tell you what's fucking crazy is those ocean currents of everything that
think,
oh,
it's from there.
Their plot,
Malaysian plastic bags.
It's probably,
you know,
from fucking big fives sports in La.
Um,
Thailand,
you're Malaysian border after rescue is found 17 pounds of plastic bags and its
stomach.
Hey,
you can't just eat one.
They like to read us.
The Washington Post reported on Sunday,
but it ultimately succumb to its illness.
The whale died on Friday,
the post road in and I tossed it was discovered that,
yeah.
Thailand's Department of Marine and coastal resource said we're 80 plastic bags
lodged in his stomach
as far from the first time wells have turned up sick or dead from ingesting
trash experts say that the whale likely believed the bags for food.
Uh,
God.
So what are we going to do about it?
What is the solution?
Okay.
Plastic pollution throughout the region is okay.
Wait a minute.
Let's see.
There's anything positive here.
According to another report by the nation,
a 2015 study by the Ocean Conservatory and Mckinsey Center for Business and
environment found that Thailand was the world's six worst offender for dumping
plastics into the sea.
So who's number one?
Silence.
Pollution Control Department says plastic waste is increasing by roughly 12%
annual with only 25% being reused.
The v I was pretty good that we reuse 25% it's better than what we used to do.
The vast majority of it is plastic bags.
The Bangkok Post writes that the 23 we're never going to get that shit out of
the ocean,
by the way.
It's like we just elk switch the cloth bags.
Oh my God,
we are a fucking plague with shoes.
Bill Hicks said that fucking 25 years ago,
the Bangkok Post writes that the 23 coastal provinces in Thailand generate
around 11 million tons of garbage daily.
I thought it was gonna be a year of which approximately 1.1 million tons ends up
being dumped directly into the seat.
Plastic pollution throughout the region is expected to remain a significant
issue.
As many Asian countries are spurring economic growth that is outpacing waste
management infrastructure.
Here's the thing,
where the fuck do you put it?
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
This is when you,
this is when you need hipsters because they're going to go,
go back the biodegradable shit.
She's trying to be cool,
but they're actually going to create a,
hopefully,
I don't know.
Oh boy.
Okay.
What the fuck are we doing?
These fucking,
what are they doing?
It's just all about the fucking money.
They don't give a fuck wars pollution.
They don't kill kids.
They don't give a fuck,
and none of these fucking politicians as a goddamn thing about it.
Okay?
It's just fucking unreal because they need the corporation's Marty.
It's just,
it's literally,
it's like a suicide pact.
How the fuck do you get out of that?
Ah,
this is the press,
like the Irish News.
It's depressing.
All right.
Massachusetts male mentality.
All right,
here we go.
Hey Bill,
I'm excited to be going to show a,
your Boston show in the fall.
By the way,
man,
I transcribed that fucking Metallica song and it might double Bass player is
finally coming together.
I just been sticking with it.
Now of course it won't be on the road for a couple of weeks,
but I'll,
I'll get it back up to speed.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
Lars has like these four or five signature licks and once you get those things
down,
you can kind of do a real shitty version of all of their songs.
I still suck,
but like I can actually,
I'm starting to be able to play along.
Uh,
I could definitely do like the,
the 16th no thing,
but he does that little,
that triplet before the snare with a crash,
uh,
China that he always does.
Dad.
That.
Yeah,
that one's a little tough.
Uh,
love your podcast.
It's one of the things that keeps me saying,
all right,
I appreciate when you say positive things about your relationship with your wife
and now you're so glad to be on the other side.
I'm a 42 year old single female and it's downright depressing around here.
I've been married so don't need to do that again.
We just like to meet someone who wants a steady monogamous relationship.
Unfortunately,
the guys around here seem to obtain their intimacy from their relationship with
their male friends.
Women are viewed as an afterthought at best,
but usually as a nuisance or a threat.
Oh,
you're in Massachusetts.
I got it is easy.
It's an easy fix.
Get into sports,
get into sports,
start watching sports,
increase your alcohol intake and your guy will be your best friend you ever had
a,
why do guys have a mob mentality when it comes to women?
They seem to think it's giving up to settle down,
but don't they fear being alone later in life?
Why did grown men care?
What their friends think and why wouldn't they be happy?
They are.
Boy is living with living a fulfilling life.
I'm cute and decent shape.
I'd say I'm a seven and a half and it looks department.
And you're humble being serious.
Yeah.
Decent shape.
You know,
you're honest.
Have a fun personality.
Can support myself.
I don't care about having kids,
but the schmucks I've been dealing with lately make me feel like giving up
altogether and another mystery to solve.
Why do my friends and I frequently see good looking good.
Why do my friends and I frequency looking guys and women who look miserable?
Uh,
if you wouldn't mind taking a few minutes to wax philosophical on the benefits
of relationship with the opposite sex,
that would be great.
Happy Birthday from a fellow Gemini.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
why did got,
why are guys afraid to settle down?
Well,
uh,
because women take guys for everything they've got in divorce court all the
fucking time.
Okay.
All right.
And like,
there's only so many of those fucking nightmares that you can,
you can watch,
um,
before you're like,
why the fuck would I want to do that?
I mean,
that was my attitude for the longest God damn time.
And um,
when you get into a relationship,
a lot of times you are at the mercy of the females moods.
Okay.
And you know,
there's,
you know,
there's all this shit out here right now talking about all the shit that guy's
do to women,
all this horrible shit.
But uh,
I'm waiting for the,
you know,
the winds to turn and pull back a little bit and talk about,
just this constant fucking like,
okay,
you know,
keeping you on eggshells.
Okay.
You know,
keep it happy,
keep her happy.
You know,
that happy,
happy wife.
Happy life is what they say.
There's no rhyme for the debt.
There isn't.
So,
you know,
and everything is about you guys.
I'm just being honest.
You know the weddings all about you.
Valentine's Day is all about you,
the anniversaries,
all about you.
It's all the guy.
What are you going to get her?
And it's like,
it's all geared that you are so fucking privileged and lucky to have this
person,
but there's really not that sort of reciprocal mentality.
So,
um,
but when you're a single guy,
you know,
you got the world by the balls,
we make more,
more money an hour at dairy queen evidently,
or whatever the fuck it is that you guys are saying.
The Tappan Zee,
Yo,
you hang out,
you watch sports,
you go down to the bar,
you talk some shit.
Maybe you get laid,
get up fucking blow job and you wake up the next day,
not in a relationship that's really appealing and you still have all your money
or a lot of it it's appealing.
Um,
I would also,
you know,
so I dunno,
I'm not,
I know you want me to say something positive.
I'm just answering that first thing.
Um,
you guys are terrifying and you act like you're not when you're talking to men,
but amongst yourselves,
you know,
amongst yourself.
I'm sure you're a little more honest about like,
you know,
the sanity
of,
uh,
you know,
so many women out there.
Yes.
There's just fucking nuts.
The fuck.
Or they'll,
they'll get pregnant on purpose.
I mean the,
the fucking,
they'll bring a person into the fucking world.
I mean,
crazy fucking crazy.
MMM.
God.
I've got to try to see something positive here.
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
why you have a problem?
Well,
you know,
you're also like,
you're like me.
You waited a while.
MMM.
All those people that are like want to find love and all that.
You know,
you got a draft in the earlier rounds,
so when you were in your 20s,
there was a bunch of blue chip prospects there.
Now you're in your 42.
You got to try to find your six round draft.
Tom Brady,
that's what you have to do.
So it's going to be more work.
Um,
but I somehow pulled it off.
MMM.
Grant,
but I was 35.
She was 25.
I Dunno,
I moved up in the draft.
That's what I did.
Maybe want a date.
A younger guy,
I dunno.
But I always looked at it this way that you know you're,
you know,
if you're out there and you seem cool,
if you're out there,
there's going to be your,
your match is going to be out there.
But like it's,
it's,
yeah,
dangerous as I just trashed women to go down that road to say they're all like
this or why does so many people blah blah blah.
You start getting fucking jaded and the reality is you could do that about
anything.
Why are most people fucking inconsiderate?
Why most people fucking morons?
Why don't most people stand in a security line at the airport,
rolling their eyes,
looking at you,
bonding it.
Like can you believe how long this is taking?
And then they do nothing to be prepared for when it's their time.
When it's showtime,
they just start to take the fucking belt off and all that and they become the
fucking problem.
They don't notice it.
Okay.
That's why meeting somebody awesome is so fucking special.
Cause there's not a lot of them out there.
So you hang in there and a,
I think you're going to find the person that wants to have the relationship you
want,
that you want and I think the relationship you're looking for is what a lot of
guys are probably looking for around your age.
Right.
If I was you,
I'd get a divorce seat.
They're already had his fucking kids already did that bullshit and then he can
just fucking,
you know,
hang with you.
You're not looking to get married and you're looking at have any fucking kids
you can just fucking hang out and drink.
Cape Cod is and watch the pets.
There you go.
Big Bang.
Boom.
Nice.
Solve your problem.
Probably not.
A wife wants to use my computer.
Oh Jason's where he got a bunch of porn on there.
Hey Billy Bob Burton.
I've dealt with my girl for five years and married for one and I refuse to let
her use my computer.
Is it because of porn or cheating is because my PC is worth close to 20 grand.
What I used to work for graphic designer,
animator and gaming A.
I didn't know they made laptops worth that much.
I even had it set up,
so I am not,
so if I'm not within three feet of it,
okay,
it is locked.
I have a piece of jewelry with an RF ID chip that unlocks my PC when I'm near
it.
Well,
I got news for you,
dude.
Anybody who wants,
who knows anything about computers can turn that fucking thing on from a
different computer when they're not even in the fucking room.
I guarantee you a,
I told her even before we were married that she will never use my computer.
She has never had a phone that wasn't cracked or broken.
And the last time she brought up my computer,
I bought her a thousand dollars PC of her own,
which she lost within a week.
Am I being too unreasonable or Imi?
Right?
Not Wanting to ruin my computer.
Do you let Nia use your computer?
Uh,
yes I do,
but like my computer's a fucking mess.
Um,
no,
I don't think,
you know,
she hasn't demonstrated that she is.
You can take care of shit.
Here's the thing,
if she's,
if she was saying you couldn't use hers,
if my wife was like,
you can't use my computer,
this is super expensive.
I do graphic designer,
I'd be like,
I don't want to use your fucking computer.
I hate computers.
Have Fun with your computer,
you know,
but um,
it probably makes her insecure because that is where porn and cheating and all
that shit fucking happens.
So I'm choosing to believe you when this,
if you're not doing that shit.
Yeah.
And if it truly is because you have this awesome fucking $20,000 fucking
computer,
uh,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know what the problem is.
Okay.
I would just sit there.
You know what I would do?
I would take her phone.
Yeah.
I would open my laptop and then I have her phone right next to it,
you know,
with the cracked screen.
I go,
look at your phone,
look at my computer.
What's the difference?
Oh,
get your PC to honey.
that's right.
You lost it.
That's right.
So now what?
What have we learned here?
And this is a thing.
Let her get mad.
Okay?
She's going to fucking storm away and be all fucking mad.
And then once again,
like I was talking about in that previous one,
she's gonna,
you know,
do that whole thing where I'm,
I'm saying the cal done a gang I'm mad at.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
she's just going to do that shit.
And you know what letter
you just,
you sit over there,
pout all you want,
you know,
I'm right.
And then they'll get mad.
They'll,
they'll switch out of the pouty thing.
Then they get fucking mad.
It's a whole goddamn process.
Just be like,
no,
you can't,
you,
I would hold my ground on that one.
Yeah.
Just say,
listen,
over the next year,
if you demonstrate that you cannot actually be around computers without breaking
them or losing them,
you know,
maybe in 12 months I'll let you look over my shoulder.
Yeah.
Just tell her that's not how works.
You have to earn things.
All right?
Most of us do anyways,
but you wouldn't know that.
Listen to all these fucking feminists out there.
I think if you're a guy,
you just fucking show up.
People give shit.
I'm still hoping it becomes a level playing field.
I can't wait.
I cannot wait.
That's going to be the greatest fucking thing ever when they realize what a
giant shit sandwich they still have to eat.
Oh,
it looked appetizing when you were peeking over the fence,
didn't it sweetheart?
All right.
That's it.
Everybody.
That's the podcast here.
Uh,
thank you to everybody over here in Ireland.
Even before I do the show.
Thank you for everybody for buying tickets to come out to the show.
It's an honor and a privilege to be here.
Get Beautiful Emerald Aisle and a,
I hope I give you money for it tomorrow night.
Uh,
go capital's Anna.
You know,
I also like the Vegas Knights to their coach gave a speech or something,
the GM the beginning of the year and then an expansion franchise if you don't
watch hockey.
And he said,
all you guys in this locker room are here for the exact same reasons.
The last team you played for didn't think you were worth being protected.
Me Right there.
They got the chip on their shoulder and they'd been fucking Moan every week.
Everybody down ever since till they ran into the Washington capitals.
Uh,
I'm going to try to find a way to somehow watch that game,
although I think tonight comes on at like two in the morning,
so I might be fucked.
Um,
and I don't know if I can't,
I can't watch the fucking NBA
Huda fuck reviews.
A charging call.
Yeah,
the final few.
I've never seen that before.
My fuck.
Oh my God.
Okay.
You know,
but thank God they did.
Thank God they did because I was able to,
I didn't have to waste time watching the rest of the fucking game.
And then I,
you know,
I went for a nice brisk walk is good for my hat.
Um,
that's it.
Guess what people were into June,
which means we are only two months away from the start of football season
preseason just like that.
It's coming around again and the God knows the way.
There's like four days off between every fucking NBA game.
You probably just going to have to do a,
you know,
the last week of June and July and then you're going to be right there.
Then you're going to be right there.
Although I've gotten back into baseball some about going to that giants game and
keeping score,
eating the peanuts,
drinking that fucking course.
Okay.
I liked it.
You know,
I went down and bought some cigars the other day.
Right?
Oh bill eat French fries.
You're smoking cigars and drinking beer.
What are you doing?
Much joy.
It myself.
Um,
I walked into this cigar shop and I gotta be honest with you.
I walked in there,
you know,
it was,
it was also a lounge where people could smoke and shit.
And I have never seen anybody smoking a cigar who did not look like they would
just totally fucking relaxed.
Okay.
Just absolutely,
absolutely in heaven,
you know,
like
true cigar smokers.
I walk in no time.
I walk in,
I just go look at that guy just sitting there
cause I always have shit to do.
So I run in and I buy them and then I run out.
But I always see people just sitting there like that's what the,
that's how you do it.
Come down in the middle of the day,
honey,
I'm going out for a minute.
Okay.
Where are you going?
No purchase.
Who is she?
Okay.
Her name is low.
Uh,
Aurora,
Emerald.
Lao,
Aurora,
Emerald.
All right.
That's it.
Everybody.
I will see you.
Okay.
Tomorrow night if you're here in Dublin,
if not,
I'll check it on your,
on Thursday.